one quick item of good news we mentioned
last hour we talked about it yesterday
we've got a couple of stories at pro
football talk calm the efforts of the
New England Patriots to send one of
their team planes to China to retrieve
1.2 million n95 masks 300,000 of those
masks have been sent by Robert Kraft the
owner of the Patriots to New York a very
inspiring gesture Kraft was on CNN last
night along with Cuomo and Kraft made it
very simple and this was a very
inspiring message that we all need to
take to heart people are looking for
good things right now this is the
greatest country in the world it's time
for us to rally together and solve these
kinds of issues and that's exactly what
Kraft did look he's got the means to do
it he's got the plane at his disposal
he's got the money to get it done but he
put it into action and it was more than
just signing a check it was finding a
way to overcome a logistical minefield
to get that plane to China it was
allowed to be on the ground for three
hours they got the 1.2 million masks
loaded in two hours and 57 minutes
before the plane had to leave so it's a
great story and it's a great inspiration
I think Peter that we all should look to
and then take a step back and say within
our own environment what can we do you
said last hour that you've at your
building you've made it clear to the
people in management that you're there
to help any of your elderly neighbors
who can't get things for themselves that
we have to be thinking about things that
we can do within wherever we are to just
help someone because by helping someone
at this time in a roundabout way you're
helping everyone you know what's the
least thing that you can do I thought
Michael Bidwell did a great thing this
past week Mike you know in some parts of
this country blood donations are down 80
percent and people are gonna have
surgery and people are gonna need blood
and he said okay we're gonna put on a
blood drive the Cardinals are gonna put
on a blood drive right inside State Farm
Stadium and on Tuesday they got 500
pints of blood
to be used in and around the state of
Arizona it went so well that they're
gonna have two more of these drives and
they're urging everybody who says
there's nothing I can do well you can at
least go in and give blood and that's
one of the things that I think has been
so good to see that all the little
things that are being done and that's
not a little thing 500 pints of blood is
huge but the little things meaning the
people who go and give the blood it's
their little tiny bit of heroism yeah
it's not gonna be one big gigantic thing
that solves this for everyone it's gonna
be an accumulation of little thing
little thing little thing spread out
over every community every state and
it's gonna be that that comes together
and I think gets us to a point where we
see the light wherever the light may be
so it's gonna require everyone anything
you can do within your own sphere of
influence do it to help someone because
if we all do that everyone is
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports